au palais bourbon un anniversaire pour
le président de la république il y à 40
ans tout juste jour pour jour il
remportait sa première bataille
électorale la première d'une longue
série c'était le 14 mars 1965 le jeune
jacques chirac 32 ans devenait
conseiller municipal à sainte féréole en
corrèze véronique sainte ollie phillips
chasse la
première campagne première main serrée
c'était qu'il y à 40 ans jacques chirac
est élu conseiller municipal de sainte
féréole
deux ans plus tard à 35 ans le voilà
député de corrèze au cul des vaches et
il s'y connaît en charolais
bistrot au plus près des gens et déjà
bernadette chirac
jacques chirac roule très vite
1967 le président georges pompidou le
nomme au gouvernement yves guéna se
souvient quand je le vois maintenant je
le retrouve toujours tels que je les ai
connus c'est à dire toujours aussi jeune
aussi dynamique aussi un crevant valéry
giscard d'estaing élu en 74 le nomme
premier ministre mais le couple très
vite explose je ne dispose pas
des moyens
que j'estime aujourd'hui
nécessaire alors jacques chirac claque
la porte du palais pour créer un outil à
sa dévotion le rpr
dans la foulée le nouveau président se
fait élire à la mairie de paris beaucoup
d'amitié mais aussi des affaires qui
éclateront plus tard
1986 retour à l'elysée jacques chirac
est le premier ministre d'une
cohabitation crispée avec françois
mitterrand
mais déjà c'est la campagne
présidentielle de 95 qui lui apporte de
l'air
7 mai 95 jacques chirac est élu
président de la république
en france et à l'étranger le nouveau
président construit sa stature chirac
incarne cette cette double capacité à
être à la fois la france dans l'histoire
et dans le monde avec tout son
rayonnement retrouvé au niveau
international et en même temps une très
grande humanité
une dissolution malheureuse en 97 une
deuxième campagne présidentielle et le 5
mai 2002 jacques chirac est réélu au
second tour contre jean marie le pen
quarante ans après les compagnons du
début ne s'étonne pas d'une telle
longévité
prenez mort quand on croit quand les
morts voilà tant qu'on refuse cette
éventualité qu on pense qu'on a un rôle
à jouer et qu'on croit en soi
alors on peut rassembler autour de soi
et reporter mais aujourd'hui si les
paris sont ouverts seul jacques chirac
sait jusqu'où il veut aller